[Applaudissements]
c'était quoi ça non c'est du lait normal
j'en ai pas
direct
le bas
[Applaudissements]
voilà un jeu de avec des gens de hockey
j'en ai ma claque quoi la bête imagine
les gens que je suis là le pad wii
les gens qui ont zappé quand même ils
ont quitté l'émission c'était un vallat
va l'avaler
s'il berbère on les avait mis en garde
croyait que le message avait été entendu
mais pas du tout il y en a qui nous
auraient attaqué ils ont le droit
arrêter avec ça pas en traître
enfin ça dépend des noms mais nous on
attaque entre être ici jamais face à
face toujours mais face à la cadette a
façonné jamais face à face vous allez
voir vous allez voir et vous allez
comprendre le premier qui nous a
attaqués en traître c'est benjamin
castaldi a et lui lâche pas la faire et
lui je suis fâché contre lui parce que
lui m'a téléphoné il m'a téléphoné le
gard
à fin septembre il m'a dit il m'a dit
arrête de parler de moi j'ai dit ok si
tu veux mais vient ici et lui continue à
paris pas venir il va venir elle va
venir abbas et bien pas bien bien qu'ils
viennent
on peut regarder on peut regarder ce
qu'il a dit
tout est là il va graver à la main il va
venir nous voir il va venir oui très
prochainement
ouais on verra s'il a un double langage
on verra non mais d'abord regarder on
peut regarder un extrait vous expliquer
ce qui s'est passé dans ce métier où
quand comment
oh bah c'est pas où c'était moi c'est à
vous il a dit il a dit exactement des
trucs sur vous il a dit vous êtes bien
tiré mais il a dit que des huit dépend
des deux vous faisiez la pluie et le
beau temps sur la chaîne mais qu'ils
viennent voir qui viennent discuter
il est aigri et jaloux c'est quoi le
problème vous n'avez pas honte castaldi
de balancer des faussetés comme ça j'en
ai marre de vous castaldi venez on va
regarder les soeurs en plus oui j'ai vu
l'extrait est franchement je vous le dis
je ne trouve pas je trouve pas ça super
méchant et c'est toujours très très
hypocrite avec lui en permanence c'est
les attaques ont plein la gueule tu
seras pas je reviens en arrière démarche
est revenue sur le l'estimé de nos jours
y revient c'est trop facile
take off c'est pas vrai j'ai pas dit que
tu étais qui fait que ça qu'à stagiaires
qu'est ce que tu as toi
[Musique]